ist das ein meilenstein auf der suche
nach außerirdischem leben einem
deutschen forschungsteam gelang jetzt
der endgültige beweis dafür dass
bestimmte mikroben in mars ähnlichen
böden nicht nur überleben sondern sogar
stoffwechsel betreiben können und mit
ihrem experiment haben sie auch noch
eine erklärung für ein mysteriöses
rätsel auf dem mars gefunden
klick zum science-fiction-epos täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
gibt es leben auf dem mars die planeten
mars saturn und jupiter gelten alle
schon seit längerer zeit als äußerst
aussichtsreiche orte in unserem
sonnensystem auf denen beziehungsweise
auf deren monden außerirdisches leben
vermutet wird und die fahndung läuft auf
hochtouren
immer wieder gibt es vor allem auf dem
mars aufsehenerregende entdeckung erst
vor kurzem hatte der mars rover
curiosity eine spannende entdeckung in
dem er milliarden altem gestein des mars
gemacht organischer materie nämlich also
sehr einfache kohlenstoffverbindungen
die hinweise auf eine lebensfreundliche
zeit auf dem roten planeten geben
konkret handelt es sich bei der
entdeckung um aromatische alle tische
und telefonische verbindung
möglicherweise ist dort also nur mal so
von mikroben gewimmelt einen
forschungsteam aus bologna hatte
außerdem und gleich einen ganzen see aus
flüssigem wasser entdeckt und zwar rund
anderthalb kilometer unter dem eis des
mars impuls die radardaten vom mars
express eine sonde der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur zeigen dies und zwar in
der südpolregion des roten planeten
planung ausstrahle
die daten zeigen in dieser abgegrenzt
region die dieselben signaturen wie
sehen unter dem eis in polar regionen
der erde und in unterirdischen seen wie
beispielsweise dem lake willens in der
antarktis wimmelt es nur so von mikroben
obwohl der see wahrscheinlich
abgeschottet ist von der außenwelt
bedeutet das etwa dass die existenz von
leben auch in diesem gletschersee das
maß wahrscheinlich ist flüssiges wasser
ist schließlich die grundvoraussetzung
für leben so wie wir es kennen
zudem gibt es ja in der marsatmosphäre
methan auf der erde entsteht methan
durch biologische prozesse
beispielsweise wenn
ihre nahrung verdauen dieser fund ist
für forschungsteams weltweit jedenfalls
super spannend denn das gas könnte ein
hinweis auf leben auf dem roten planeten
seien messungen hatten außerdem gezeigt
dass die konzentrationen des methans das
jahr über stark schwanken
ist das etwa ein beweis für biologische
aktivitäten ausgeschlossen ist es
allerdings nicht dass das methan durch
geologische prozesse freigesetzt wird
denn das gas kann auch biochemisch
entstehen zum beispiel durch die uv
bestrahlung von gesteinsmaterial die
große frage zu diesem mysteriösen rätsel
lautet also wer oder was produziert
sporadisch dieses methan
die forschungsgruppe um den
astrobiologen dirk schulze makuch vom
zentrum für astronomie und astrophysik
an der tu berlin gehört mit zum projekt
home das steht für heavy tablet of march
war immens und die fachleute
beschäftigen sich schon seit vielen
jahren intensiv mit der lebens
freundlichkeit potenzieller lebensräume
auf dem mars so konnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
schon von zwei jahren 2018 zeigen dass
aktive zellverbände unter maß ähnlichen
bedingungen so lange überleben können
bis sie durch minimale wassermengen
wieder aktiviert werden diese
untersuchungen wurden in der atacama
willst du durchgeführt diese region ist
mars ähnlich denn sie gehört zu den
trockensten orten der welt nun hat sich
die berliner arbeitsgruppe genauer mit
dem mysteriösem methan rätsel befasst
dass die fachwelt schon seit jahren
beschäftigt in einem experiment wiesen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nach dass bestimmte
mikroben in salzhaltigen böden die dem
dass masse ähnlich sind nicht nur
überleben können
die in der fachsprache als allen
bekannten mikroben sind sogar in der
lage in dieser eigentlich
lebensfeindlichen umgebung stoffwechsel
zu betreiben das ist wirklich eine
spektakuläre erkenntnis denn die mars
ähnlichen böden beten ihnen nicht fehlt
vorhanden sind lediglich minimale
wassermengen und zudem auch nur zwei
energie und kraftstoff quellen
wasserstoff und kohlendioxid dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam in der
aktuellen studie die niedrige
durchschnittstemperatur und
wasseraktivitäten an der oberfläche des
mars machen dass lebenden organismen
nicht leicht in dieser umgebung zu
bestehen oder sich gar fortzupflanzen
doch die ergebnisse jüngerer
mars-mission zeigen
dass die umweltbedingungen zu bestimmten
zeiten und an bestimmten orten des roten
planeten durchaus die unseren grenzen
überschreiten die leben möglich machen
doch wie gelangen die mikroben an das
wasser das er als grundbedingung für
leben gilt an der marsoberfläche
jedenfalls ist flüssiges wasser nicht
dauerhaft vorhanden
nach ansicht des forschungsteams könnten
die mikroben mit hilfe von sogenannten
hygroskopisch in salzen an feuchtigkeit
gelangen diese werden in der nähe der
mars oberfläche vermutet und entziehen
ihrer umgebung feuchtigkeit
beispielsweise dem morgenfrost das salz
wandelt sich dann von fest zu flüssig
was wiederum die dunklen streifen an den
steilen wänden einiger master erklären
würde diese regierungslinie also so
etwas wie fleece spuren wurden bereits
auch von anderen fachleuten mit der
existenz solcher mikroskopischer salze
in oberflächennähe erklärt diese könnten
also den dort lebenden organismen dabei
behilflich sein ihren wasserbedarf zu
decken so die these des deutschen
forschungsteams die mikroben
gemeinschaften in den mars ähnlichen
gebeten wie etwa der atacama wüste in
chile oder aber den so genannten
lassmann hills im osten der antarktis
zeigen dass diese sich der umgebung
optimal angepasst haben sobald sie
befeuchtet werden beginnen sie
stoffwechsel zu betreiben den prozess
dieser befeuchtung wird in der
fachsprache als d league west ends
bezeichnet es handelt sich um die
fähigkeit spezifischer stoffe die
relative feuchte der umgebung zu
beeinflussen meist sind es als dazu dirk
schulze makuch die untersuchung dieser
maß analogen umgebungen und der dort
vorhandenen micro biota helfen die
bewohnbarkeit von marianischen
umgebungen zu bewerben für ihr aktuelles
experiment schufen die berliner
fachleute ein geschlossenes daily quests
ins system
darin enthalten maß analoge substrate
hygroskopisch salze und drei metern og
aachen konkret handelt es sich um die
drei micro stämme metaller cgm war
carrie & m solide
dann wurde die messung gestartet um so
herauszufinden unter welchen bedingungen
die mikroben mit ihren stoffwechsel
aktivitäten beginnen das große ziel des
experiments bestand darin zu testen ob
die schwankungen
konzentration auf dem mars von mikroben
stammen können die oberflächennahe auf
dem roten planeten existieren und das
ergebnis ist eindeutig zwei der drei
organismen wurden in jeweils
verschiedenen substraten bei
verschiedenen temperaturen quasi zum
leben erweckt und das ist eine riesige
überraschung sogar für die fachleute
selbst dazu dirk schulze makuch nach
unserer kenntnis gibt es jedoch keine
studie die belegt dass mit halogen in
einer oberflächennahen umgebung
existieren können in der wasser nur
durch den existenz verfügbar gemacht
werden kann wir konnten hier zum ersten
mal zeigen dass allein das durch die
delinquenz bereitgestellte wasser
ausreicht um mit halogen unter diesen
extremen bedingungen erneut zu vibrieren
quasi wieder zum leben zu erwecken und
deren stoffwechsel in einer umgebung zu
reaktivieren wie sie nahe unter der
oberfläche des mars existiert bisherigen
experimente hatten vor allem bestimmte
stressfaktoren unter die lupe genommen
um die bewohnbarkeit auf dem mars zu
testen unter anderem dabei dürre hunger
austrocknung und gefrier und auftaut
zyklen
somit handelt es sich hier also um die
erste studie die die eigenschaften und
das verhalten von methanol genen aachen
untersucht und dabei auch noch zu der
erkenntnis kommt dass diese in einer
umgebung existieren können in der wasser
alleine durch den vorgang der den eac
westends verfügbar gemacht wird heißt
also im klartext das mysteriöse methan
auf dem mars könnte tatsächlich von
mikroben stammen us forscher behauptet
es gibt lebende insekten auf dem mars
anklicken angucken abonnieren giggs 1 1
am feature freuen uns über jede
unterstützung für unseren täglichen
videos werden gerne kanal mitglied dann
bekommt ihr die videos früher vor allen
anderen
das geht hier unter dem video und auf
unser kanal seite also bis dann bleibt
dran